На жаль я бачу депутатам не цікаво Але я
продовжу розповідати вам про реальне
життя в державі на те вигадане ваше в
якому ви там собі зараз живете
а отримуючи свою константу десь маючи в
планах відпочинок де там на яких
чергових островах чи ще десь а реальне
життя а реальне життя таке ми говоримо
цей бюджет має бути воюючої країни
військо в пріоритеті а тепер розкаж каж
вам про реальність нашого війська А вона
така людина віддає своє здоров'я за
державу стає не придатним наприклад до
дшв чи інших таких серйозних військ
людину виводять поза штат і людина
починає отримувати 600 700 800 грн на
місяць не на день не на Одну каву ні на
місяць но це ж ганьба змініть це